[Music]
coffee
it's the lifeblood of your average day
grind the beans load the filter add
water brew and enjoy but do you know
what's inside that cup of coffee you're
drinking mostly its water over 98% of a
cup but the other 2% is the really good
stuff the first thing you notice is the
aroma actually some of the compounds in
coffee would be pretty repulsive if they
were present in higher concentrations
like two ethyl phenol which has a tie
like medicinal odor it also happens to
be a cockroach pheromone the bugs use it
to warn each other of danger
there's also dimethyl disulfide it's
just barely detectable in your cup of
joe which is lucky since it smells a bit
like rotting meat but of course coffee
still tastes pretty darn good rich
acetyl methyl carbon all lends a buttery
taste no surprise since it's a component
of actual butter trigana lean gives
coffee it's sweet earthy taste and it
also battles cavity-causing bacteria
streptococcus mutans keeping the
critters from attaching to your teeth
but the real health superstar is 3 5 to
cap your Clinic acid which protects your
brain from free radical damage that's
right coffee
is an antioxidant once you've had a few
slugs your favorite ingredient kicks in
caffeine it's actually an alkaloid plant
toxin like nicotine and cocaine but
don't let that scare you in your brain
it blocks receptors for the
neurotransmitter adenosine result you
awake want milk and sugar with that well
that's a whole other episode feeling
wired yet subscribe